ex gewählt 40 spaß die bleibt stehen
alter bleibt stehen bleibt stehen bleibt
stehen bleibt stehen bleibt stehen
bleibt stehen bleibt stehen bleibt
stehen bleibt stehen ist den 8
wie dumm ist eine bitte
so ist man nicht bauen denken weil das
ein bisschen so dingsbums sodann geht
schon klar
was man natürlich alles hier kann ich
jetzt mein jetpack ist alle damals hat
sich das noch über nacht aufgeladen
jetzt wird sich wie aus zwei blöcke über
mir waren
und kann nicht einfach nur heftig hüpfen
in der nacht jedoch klappt so dann werde
ich jetzt richtig aber benötigen fall
direkt beim einem ding runter wartet
yahoo
ja ich glaube ich weiß nicht mal was um
jaffé für von daher dass rapper kann ich
mal wieder rausnehmen
so kann ich denn jetzt die blackbox
einfach abbauen oder dass da etwas
passiert ist die frage
freunde wollen wir machen übrigens mal
in allem macht hier eine bessere french
damit nicht alles kaputt geht
ok bevor ich den abbau mache ich mir
eine bessere
doch da electric ranch der batterie
elektronik sorgt und rancher dass er
einfach batterien machen
das waren lava kennt bei mir drin
batterien habe ich dann mehr und sollte
nie mehr
zack zack verdammt wie mache ich das
jetzt die krisen ja der krise heraus
kann ich dann nicht auch in dem pulver
ausmacht nämlich der mehr aus kriegen
ja aber ich kann es doch einfach mal
nichts tun so kann ich bett box mit
rasch abbauen ohne dass sie kaputt geht
ich wollte das übrigens alles mal ein
bisschen anders hin stellen weil mich
das ein bisschen aufregt wenn das ganze
so die ganze zeit steht freunde
jo
dass die welt box
so wie mussten jetzt in f&e hinstellen
mich dass ich falsch mache ich verkackt
ich glaube ich bin wieder da
babette noch drin
warte ich kann nicht mehr schreiben
ja cool da mache ich mir erst mal der
elektronik ranch damit es nicht kaputt
geht wie ist die chance mit elektrisch
ich hoffe das geht dann komplett klar
übrigens ja mein haus wird noch gebaut
allerdings möchte ich mir jetzt erstmal
hier im sms zu ende machen und brauchen
deswegen wollte ich ja hier die ua
prozent im spezial modus m + rechtsklick
ist doch karten funktionen von skype
angeschriebenen
hallo vielleicht muss es auch ein proben
ändern weil sie nicht doch funktioniert
schon ja gut dann klappt das ja jetzt
dass es war nur weil nacht war
wahrscheinlich wird kann man das immer
ganz kurz und achtet mal auf den slot
das mal ganz kurz ein jetpack drin ein
jetpack legt sich gerade auf die
postkutsche ich hab das übrigens jetzt
eingestellt warum rechts da steht jetzt
mal auf welchem bock drauf gucke freunde
ja sagt funktioniert da kommst du rein
und die kommt ja raus diese ganzen
allerdings passiert werde ich übrigens
da werde ich erstmal meine chainsaw
reinpacken mal wie schnell das geht das
ist richtig geil
fertig deswegen habe ich mit mlp
gebauten diese ganzen
ich hab keine knochen
ich hab keine knochen dann wäre ich
jetzt mal nach unten gehen von monster
klatschen um den park noch holen sind
daneben muss kletter oder so alles
wasser hätten für einen blog was ist
dies für einen block stinknormale ja was
wollt ihr denn jetzt ich möchte doch nur
kommen wir damit ihr seht ihr mich hier
garantiert werde
ich habe jetzt gar keine rüstung dass
die zehn grad das problem alter schreibt
mal bitte noch lauter
so endlich halten sich schmutzig blöden
ändern berlin kommen dass mein haus oder
raum habe ich das sagen sie nicht
sie sind auch noch krass viele ärzte die
maschine alle noch abbauen aber auch
außerdem ein einige dass ich in strip
meinem programm da eingeben soll werde
ich bald auch machen allerdings finde
ich dass derzeit relativ langweilig wenn
man strip beim programm hat dann alle
items hat ich mache das lieber so dass
der hier alles mal abfahren
ich habe meine klasse super
ist ja nicht so dass ich jetzt gegen
tomis und männer man kämpfe also nur
macht mir nix mining filmteam leute kann
ich ändern nennt sich irgendwie
verscheucht wenn ich einfach ein
separates mal durch fluten
so das war's nur noch 40
ich glaube es war 40
ex gewählt 40
spaß die app stehen
alter bleibt stehen bleibt stehen map
stehen bleibt stehen bleibt stehen
bleibt stehen bleibt stehen bleibt
stehen bleibt stehen
wie dumm ist eine bitte
das schmerzt kommission reinigen ich
brauche
ohne wissen der geht einfach mal die
falsche richtung tut mir leid simon aber
ich werde das wieder zu bauen aber
trotzdem sehr dumm
ich habe 1000 mal gesagt wir wollen die
andere richtung gehen an die da stand
wahrscheinlich einfach nur falsch rum
er war trotz widerstand auch richtig rum
der dotter vor ort mache ich nicht
gebaut
herr luca du bist ein vollidiot dass sie
dauernd daran ja dann schreibt mittel
hier unten ist muss auf jeden fall noch
ein bisschen ausgehöhlt werden damit ihr
dann so ein riesiges loch ist einfach
direkt an meinem grundstück gehört habe
ich auch wieder bisschen erfahrung
kämpfen das noch allerdings das was
eigentlich kein spender so sind diese
karte dort sauber ja freuen ich werd
ball zaubern
ich beantworte man schon so die ganzen
kommentare jetzt wie wir immer wieder
gestellt werden ja ich lese kommentare
frage mich auch ganz viele leute
ach so meine andere spitzhacke wollte
dafür übrigens eigentlich immer
verbrauchen
dann kann ich ihn nicht mitnehmen
ich brauche ich nicht unnötig die teile
brauche ich oder
ich weiß nicht was besser kann ich mir
das nicht das machen oder so rea diesen
immer in den blöcken
wo ist es denn besser wenn ich mit
blöcke mache bei diamant ist das besser
weil wir ja ich war ich weiß übrigens
dass ich ein vollidiot war ich habe eine
menge kommentare gelesen auf ihren der
klausurphase ich weiß dass ich ein
vollidiot war weil ich die ganzen
letzten sachen immer so als blöcke
abgebaut hat und dann in major gepackt
und dann redstone stopp kommen habe ich
weiß wenn man die abbaut kriegt man so
komplett fünf redstone so auf einmal das
habe ich total verpennt in dem moment in
dem moment als er richtig viele zweige
kohle nehme ich alles mit brauche ich
auch alles cool ist einfach nur das ein
und alles
daraus kann richtig viele diamanten
machen da fühle mich richtig stolz
ich nehme es aber auch nur noch 20
minuten auf ein danach muss ich mich
gezwungen dann lädt hat wahrscheinlich
auch nix mit einem hausbau aber ist ja
egal wenn ich da noch im nächsten tag
weiter aufnehmen ist es ja egal welcher
euch ist ja eh morgen bzw dann heute
abend noch ich weiß nicht wie viel ich
schaffe aufzunehmen wer dann noch etwas
aufnehmen mit gamma
muss ich halt alles gucken das ist für
euch jetzt immer komisch wenn ich so
sagen ja ich nehme jetzt noch auf
vielleicht habt ihr dann schon die
ganzen folgen gesehen aber ich weiß es
nicht
das ist also ein bisschen crazy daisy
you know that's life man hier ist noch
was ich erzähle ich weiß ihr denkt euch
jetzt nötig weil viele wissen auch
wahrscheinlich jetzt das mittlerweile
dass man daraus diamant machen kann aber
trotzdem es ist zwar sehr anstrengend
hier so die ganze zeit dabei zu stehen
und das ist auch relativ langweilig das
einfach abzubauen
da sind zwei ärzte mit einfach mal zwei
kommission hat unnötig hoch 1000 diese
zwei komischen die brauchen der dieses
komische erzeugt
eisen ist importance
in diesen kohle
lacht ja alle dass wieder alle mann
warum kann ich mehr fliegen alter wir
sollten jetzt herauskommen zu fliegen
ich habe die gar nicht eingesammelt
glaube ich ist auch immer wichtig wegen
kupferkabel bla bla bla bla bla
hier sind auch noch überall ärzte am
rand das wird nach der sonne durch
koppelte fläche hier sein dass es
unglaublich dass wird so unfassbar
scheiße aussehen
ich frage mich warum ich das überhaupt
angefangen hat aber einfach nur damit
meinem einigen tipps was machen kann
zeigen kann dass sie auch etwas kann ich
habe diese stolze gras viel körper
wir sind sie beide auf karadzic sagen
und freundlichen blödmänner
die kamera zum höhlen sound als das
erste höhle okay hier ist alles
ausgeräumt von daher wird ihr das wohl
den sound erzeugt haben
diese ganze konstanzer die brauche ich
nie meinem leben noch mal für mein haus
brauche ich auch kein haitien
cobblestone deswegen werde ich dir auch
nicht für seinen hausbau brauchen außer
vielleicht später wenn ich unten dass
wir dazu bericht aber möchte hier noch
laufen noch